[Music]
as a very general rule
there are three types of information
that are encoded in genomes
probably the one that most people are
familiar with are genes that encode
proteins
but in the human genome this represents
only five percent
or even a little less of the entire
genome
there are also regions and nobody really
knows at present exactly where they all
are
and how big they are but we know very
well they exist
and we've identified many of them that
control when genes are turned on or off
and how much these are so-called
regulatory regions
there are two different parts of the
regulator regions
there are promoters that are located
just before a particular gene that
regulate gene transcription
and there are other more mysterious
parts that are called enhancers
located far away from the gene in
question
it turns out that the enhancers which we
think of as being very far away
from the gene in question actually may
not be so far away
that's because up to now we've been
studying dna and genomics in two
dimensions
but life is in three dimensions for a
molecule of dna
we can stretch it out measure it and
read it in the ways that the modern
technology allow us to do
but that's not how it works in the body
that's not how it works inside the cell
the dna molecules are coiled and when
you look at three-dimensional aspects of
dna
you sometimes find that these enhancers
that previously mysteriously seem to be
very far away from the gene they are
regulating
are actually quite close by and that's
one of the really exciting new areas
studying dna in three dimensions and
when you include a time component to
that
actually for dimensions so a whole new
science of 4d genomics is taking shape
to understand the physical structure of
a genome
and the temporal aspects under which it
functions
the third type of important element that
you find also in all organisms
are regions genes that encode rna
molecules
and rna molecules are also essential
components of every cell
another part has to do with parts of the
genome that aren't regulatory
and that are not genes and that are
actually relics of genes past
there's a lot of stretches of the genome
that don't currently or produce any
functional
proteins but yet it's still part of a
long stretch
and it still gets copied and passed down
from generation to generation
a lot of this has been referred to as
junk dna
and there's a bit of debate about
whether it's truly junk
one of the best explanations about it
was that don't confuse junk with trash
trash is useless you throw away junk is
what you keep in your garage because it
might one day be useful or used to be
useful and then it broke
but it's still there so you keep it you
pass it on
so there's a difference between junk and
trash
we think that maybe large parts of the
genome which don't have what we think of
as functional genes in them
had been there because large parts of
the genome can get copied and put in a
different location
so if we think about genes as reflecting
the genome as a recipe book
as an instruction book there's a whole
other side to the genome
and that is the genome as a history book
reflecting the evolutionary history of
that particular species
this has been a marvelous area of
discovery leading to all sorts of
insights
especially but not limited to our
understanding of human evolution
we can read the genome as a history book
looking at these parts of the genome
that aren't actually genes at this point
in time